[Music]
let's go to brooklyn new york
leon joins us there leon how can we help
yes uh good afternoon ken chris uh first
of all my wife loves your show
and i've learned a lot so uh thank you
for the work that you're doing
thank you i need some i need some help
here i need some guidance
i want to buy a home to take advantage
of the low interest rates
um i just graduated with my mba
i've accumulated 202 000
of debt wow um now not only that
but i'm married i have three children
all
under five i recently lost my job
so my wife is the only one that is
working right now
and so we're trying to figure out
options
and you know just looking for a little
guidance here
well guidance specifically what on how
to get out of debt because you we have
dave ramsey's baby steps i mean what
what specifically are you looking
guidance
uh for so sure sure ken so i want to
find out
should i try to get a home now no
no no no not at all no
no it shouldn't even be in your mind
yeah not not at this point and here's
the reason leon
you know how you feel when you did the
math and you figured out how much you
owed in student loan debt you remember
when you looked at that total number
i did okay what you don't want to do is
compound that by adding now the stress
of a mortgage
okay i've been to brooklyn several times
and you know the home prices up in that
area
so what you guys want to do first and
foremost is you've got to get some
income coming back in
asap and you guys need to map
out a plan a three-year plan
uh maybe three and a half on how you're
going to chop this debt
and get it out of your life and i
wouldn't even think of home until this
was gone
and i know you go well chris hold on man
i want to
i understand but i'm just telling you so
you don't become like people i've talked
to that have had student loans hanging
around for 15 to 20 years
you want to get intentional right now
you've got your three kids you said
they're all under three
under five all under five can you
imagine
that's right and it's okay because
there's no law that says kids need to
live in a home
right by the way they don't care they
want you and
you've got an opportunity in three years
to get this out of your life and evicted
how much is the payment on that 202 000
well i haven't started to pay it yet
just because of the act that recently
but if if i did decide uh when i do have
to start paying it will be about 1500 a
month
okay so imagine you're freeing up 1500
a month you pay off this student loans
you start to get intentional get that
out of your life then redirect that 1500
toward the down payment
my friend in about four years you can
have a remarkable turnaround
and be in a home what does your wife
make right now what's she bringing home
uh excuse me just give me the gross sure
87 000. she's making 87. what were you
making
i was making 134. okay
134 000. i i got to tell you the number
one focus right now is if you got the 1
000
emergency fund we're going to walk the
baby steps out and if you don't have any
other debt
do you have any other debt besides the
student loans
no just a car uh lease payment that i
have
okay well we need to get rid of that
what's that cost you
that's about uh 6 15 a month okay leon
listen to me
watch out all right i'm going to send
you dave's total money makeover book
now you need to read it twice
and i want you to look at this thing and
go all right hold on i'm gonna take
control of my future
you know why you got three little kids
counting on you
okay three of them and so we're not
gonna get caught up with what the
joneses think we're not worrying about
what the neighbors think
i want you all to get very intentional
about what it is you're doing and why
you got these kids waiting and you've
got an incredible opportunity to take
them on a journey
and you can have this stuff paid off and
they'll never know you can have it out
of your life
but leases credit cards one clicks
boxes showing up we gotta all put that
on lock buddy yeah we gotta start to
tighten the belt and get intentional
leon listen
i wanna we're not getting on you but
we're trying to be the wake up call okay
now listen
um you don't need a car
in brooklyn you just don't
so you got to get out of that lease you
got to figure out how to get out of that
lease so your focus is
you've got to get as close as you can to
that 134 000
in in income i understand that that that
covett is here
your wife's still working but this is
you working as hard as you can
and you're gonna have to give up a
little bit of time with those kiddos
maybe you're gonna have to get
after it because that lease we gotta get
out of the lease first
that's 600 and some dollars a month that
you need that can help
really pay down and go towards this
gazelle intensity
that chris is talking about but man you
this is this is
all in right now you do not need a car
in brooklyn
new york not in 2020 chris yeah no this
is you can get anywhere you need to go
yeah he's got to get fired up right now
he's curious about getting out of debt
and what i was wanting to do was i want
him to look at this and really see it
and go no no no i've got to be committed
to getting out of debt
and you're right that lease that's 615
dollars that could be going toward
the student loan i mean he could be
throwing 2100 at the student loan
but we got to change our thinking guys
and gals and
again you're going to have to give up
something to get something better
you just are it's true in sports it's
true in life it's true with money
and we just have to decide is it really
worth it yeah and and while we're at it
you know when you're looking at a
situation like this leon and anybody
else
you know what if the if your wife is is
working in brooklyn or in manhattan
then we we took a caller you know
earlier in the show
gotta move gotta get out of the city
yeah where we can lower our cost
that's that's found money no it is and
that's an option but people don't like
to think of that kid well but i don't
care
you because because i'm feisty well i'm
just saying you got to think about
every area of your life where you
sacrifice it's not just
income it's also cutting stuff so that
you go all right
we're going to sacrifice now these
little kids they just love mom and dad
they don't care they don't know how i
used to think my first house was
monstrous i went back and saw it when i
was in my early 30s and i was like
we lived in that this is the same house
you're telling me that
we got pictures it was like a postage
stamp right on cinder block
not to you in the day but i thought it
was huge and those little ones
they don't care and so leon i know as a
husband and a father you want to provide
and i know you want to be further along
and that's what you're trying you're
trying to figure out how do i provide
this
nice house while i dig myself out well
guess what
you can't you just can't you can't do
the house
and dig yourself out and that doesn't
make you less of a man
not at all it doesn't make you less of a
husband and it doesn't make you less of
a father let me tell you what makes you
a great man
and a great husband and a great father
is leading your wife
through this storm this debt and you can
get out of it
so hang on the line kelly uh chris gave
him uh totally
total money makeover absolutely um i'd
really like to put him in ramsey plus
since we're giving stuff away this this
is this is our
subscription program where he's gonna
get fpu financial peace university
all of the classes you're going to get
our world-class
budgeting app every dollar which is a
game changer leon
and then you're going to get the
tracking device really it's
it's an app and it's called the baby
step tracker and so it's going to really
give you a scoreboard and now here's
what i love most for him ken
it's going to give him community he's
going to get plugged in there
he's going to be able to get connected
he can go get connected in the baby
steps community
facebook group right now uh or hop over
to my everyday millionaire facebook
group
uh they're in there 18 to 80. uh love to
connect with you
and have fun yeah good stuff and he can
do it and folks if
there's many of you right now that are
listening you're going man i feel like
i'm in the same situation the details
are different that's right but i'm in
the same situation and
you know this is not your sentence
this is your situation it's a big
difference get out of this
but you've got to believe that there's a
way and we've given you away so